welcome everyone to part two in our
series on natural language inference uh
we're going to focus on the three data
sets that we'll be concentrating on this
unit which are snli the stanford natural
language inference corpus multi-nli and
adversarial nli i think they're
interestingly different and they're all
big benchmark tasks that can support the
training of lots of diverse kinds of
systems
so let's begin with snli which is the
first to appear of these three the
associated paper is bowman at all 2015.
sam bowman was a student in the nlp
group and i was his advisor along with
chris manning
and a bunch of us contributed to that
paper
uh an important thing to know about snli
is that the premises are all image
captions from the image flicker 30k data
set so that's an important genre
restriction that you should be aware of
when you think about training systems on
this data
all the hypotheses were written by crowd
workers i'll show you the prompt in a
little bit but the idea is they were
given this premise which was an image
caption and then they wrote three
different texts corresponding to the
three nli labels
unfortunately as is common with crowd
source data sets you should be aware
that some of the sentences do reflect
stereotypes i think this traces to the
fact that crowd workers trying to do a
lot of work
are faced with a creative block and the
way they overcome that is by falling
back on easy tricks and some of those
involved stereotypes completely
understandable and this is something
that the field is trying to come to
grips with as we think about data set
creation
it's a big data set it has over 550 000
training examples and it has dev and
test sets each of 10 000 examples
balanced across the three classes here's
a look at the mean token links it's just
sort of noteworthy that premises are a
little bit longer than hypotheses i
guess that comes down to the fact that
crowd workers were writing these
sentences
the in terms of clause types mostly we
talk about nli as a sentence task but in
fact um only 74 of the examples are
sentences that is s rooted in their
syntactic parses it has a large
vocabulary but maybe modest relative to
the size of the data set and that might
come back to the fact that the genre is
kind of restricted
we had about 60 000 examples that were
additionally validated by four other
annotators and i'll show you the
response distributions which suggest
some sources of variation
they had high inter-annotator agreements
so given that validation
about 60 percent of examples had a
unanimous goal label and we rate the
overall human level of agreement at
about 91.2
for the gold labels and that's kind of
the measure of human performance that's
commonly used for snli
uh the overall flights cap measure inter
annotator agreement is 0.7 which is
which is a high rate of agreement and
then for the leaderboard you can check
out this link here sam has been good
about curating all the systems that
enter and you can get a sense for which
approaches are best it's clear at this
point for example that ensembles of deep
learning methods are the best for this
problem
i mentioned before the crowdsourcing
methods i think it's worth thinking
about precisely what happened here so
here's the crowdsourcing interface
there's some instructions up here here's
the caption that is the premise sentence
in our terms a little boy in an apron
helps his mother and then the crowd
worker had to come up with three
sentences one definitely correct that's
an entailment case
one may be correct that is our gloss on
neutral and one definitely incorrect
which is our gloss on contradiction so
you can see here that there's an attempt
to use informal language connecting with
informal reasoning common sense
reasoning
in the prompt here and then those get
translated into our three labels for the
task
and here are some examples from the
validated set and i think they're sort
of interesting because you get high
rates of agreement but you do find some
examples that have a lot of uncertainty
about them like this last one here
and i think that might be a hallmark
actually of nli problems
now one really fundamental thing that i
mentioned in the overview screencast is
definitely worth being aware of relates
specifically to the contradiction
relation and there's discussion of this
in the paper it's a tricky point
what we say for snli using these simple
examples here is that both of them are
in the contradiction relation the first
one is a boat sank in the pacific ocean
as premise and hypothesis about boat
sank in the atlantic ocean you might ask
of course those could be true together
they should be neutral not contradiction
the reason we call them contradiction is
because we make an assumption of event
co-reference that we're talking about
the same boat in the same event and
therefore the locations contradict each
other in a common sense way
and the second example is an even more
extreme case of this ruth bader ginsburg
was appointed to the supreme court and i
had a sandwich for lunch today we say
those are in the contradiction relation
of course they could be true together
but they couldn't in our terms be true
of the same event
they're describing very different events
and for that reason they get the
contradiction label
if a premise and hypothesis probably
describe a different photo than the
label is contradiction that's the kind
of anchoring back into our underlying
domain that you might have in mind
we can mark progress on snli because sam
has been curating that leaderboard as i
mentioned before we estimate human
performance up here at almost 92 and
along this x-axis here i've got time
and you can see that very quickly the
community has hill climbed toward
systems that are super human according
to our estimate right down here at 78 is
the original paper that was from an era
when deep learning systems were really
not clearly the winners in this kind of
competition but snli helped change that
by introducing a lot of new data so you
very very rapid rise in system
performance and then basically monotonic
increase until 2019 when we saw the
first systems that were in these
restrictive terms better than humans at
the snli task
let's move to multi-nli which was a kind
of um
successor to snli this was collected by
adina williams and colleagues including
sam bowman
um the trained premises in this case are
going to be much more diverse they're
drawn from five genres fiction
government reports and letters and
things the slate website
the switchboard corpus which is people
interacting over the phone
and berlitz travel guides
and then interestingly they have
additional genres just for dev and test
and this is what they call the
mismatched condition and those are the
911 report
face-to-face conversations
fundraising letters and non-fiction from
oxford university press as well as
articles about linguistics
so this is noteworthy because in the
mismatched condition that that
multi-noise sets up you are forced to
train on those train examples and then
test on entirely new genres you can just
see how different for example berlin's
travel guides might be from the 911
report i think this is an interesting
early example of being adversarial and
of forcing our systems to grapple with
new domains and new genres i think
that's a really productive step in
testing these systems for robustness
it's another large data set slightly
smaller than snli but actually the
example lengths tend to be longer they
did the same kind of a validation and
that gives us our estimates of human
performance and once again i would say
that we can have a lot of confidence
there was a high rate of agreement
92.6 is the traditional measure of human
performance here
for multi-analyte the test set is
available only as a kaggle competition
and you can check out the product
project page here
i love the fact that multi-nli was
distributed with annotations that could
help someone kind of do out-of-the-box
error analysis what they did is have
linguists go through and label specific
examples for whether or not they
manifested specific linguistic phenomena
like do the premise and hypothesis
involve variation in active passive
morphology which might be a clue that
the sentences are synonymous or an
entailment relation
but nonetheless hard for systems to
predict because of the change in word
order also things like whether there are
belief statements conditionals whether
co-references involved in a non-trivial
way modality negation quantifiers things
that you might think would be good
probes for the true systematicity of the
model you've trained and you can use
these annotations to kind of benchmark
yourself there i think that's incredibly
productive
how we doing on multi-noi so again we're
going to have our score over here and on
the x-axis time
we have that human estimate at 92.6
and since it's on kaggle we can look at
lots more systems for snli we just have
the published papers but on kaggle lots
of people enter and they try lots of
different things as a result you get
much more variance across this it's much
less monotonic but nonetheless you can
see that the community is rapidly hill
climbing toward superhuman performance
on this task as well and again i would
just want to reiterate recalling themes
from our introductory lecture this does
not necessarily mean that we have
systems that are super human at the task
of common sense reasoning which is a
very human and complex thing but rather
systems that are just narrowly
outperforming humans on this one
particular very machine-like metric
which gives us our estimate of human
performance here
still stripe startling progress
and then finally adversarial nli is kind
of a response to that dynamic that looks
like we're making lots of progress but
we might worry that our systems are
benefiting from idiosyncrasies and
artifacts and the data sets and that
they're not actually good at the human
kind the kind of human reasoning that
we're truly trying to capture and that
gave rise to the adversarial nli project
the paper is me at all which also
involves some authors from earlier data
sets snli and multi-nli
it's another large data set a little bit
smaller but um you'll see why it's
special in some respects
the premises come from very diverse
sources we don't have the genre
overfitting you might get from snoi
and the hypotheses were again written by
crowd workers but here crucially they
were written not in the abstract but
rather with the goal of fooling
state-of-the-art models that's the
adversarial part of this project
this is a direct response to this
feeling that results in findings for
snli and multi-nli while impressive
might be overstating the extent to which
we've made progress on the underlying
task of common sense reasoning
so here's how the data set collection
worked in a little more detail this is a
fascinating dynamic the annotator was
presented with a premise sentence and
one condition which would just
correspond to the label that they want
to create
they write a hypothesis
and a state-of-the-art model makes a
prediction about the premise hypothesis
pair basically predicting one of these
three condition labels
if the model's prediction matches the
conviction the annotator returns to step
two to try again with a new sentence
if the model was fooled though the
premise hypothesis pair is independently
validated so in this way we're kind of
guaranteed to get a lot of examples that
are very hard for whatever model we have
in the loop in this process
are some more details so it has three
rounds this data set for its first
release
um
overall that results in that large data
set
and you can see that in subsequent
rounds the model is going to be expanded
to include previous rounds of data in
addition possibly to other data
resources
and so what we're hoping is that as we
progress through these rounds these
examples are going to get harder and
harder in virtue of the fact that the
model is trained on more data and is
getting better as a result of seeing all
this adversarial examples
in terms of the splits the train set is
a mix of cases where the model's
predictions were correct and where it
was incorrect because sometimes in that
loop the annotator was unable to fool
the model after some specified number of
attempts and we keep those examples
because they're nonetheless interesting
training data however
um
in the dev and test sets we have only
examples that fold the models so from
with respect to the best model for each
round the test set is as adversarial as
it could possibly get the model has
gotten every single example wrong
and adversarial nli is exciting because
it's given rise to a whole movement
around creating adversarial data sets
and that's represented by this open
source project dynavench
we just recently published a paper
that's on the dynabench effort reporting
on a bunch of tasks that are going to
use approximately adversarial nlr-like
techniques to develop data sets that are
adversarial in lots of domains and
you've actually seen one of these in the
dynacent
data set from our previous unit on
sentiment analysis
and here's the dynabench interface and i
guess i'm just exhorting you if you
would like to get involved in this
effort it's a community-wide thing to
develop better benchmarks that are going
to get us closer to assessing how much
progress we're actually making
and then finally there are a lot of
other nli data sets that i didn't
mention so let me just run the through
these the glue benchmark has a lot of
nli tasks in it
as does super glue which is its
successor
i mentioned before in the context of
anli this nli style fever data set fever
is fact verification and they've just
translated the examples into noi ones
here's an analytics corpus that's on for
chinese and here's one for turkish the
turkey the chinese examples are all
original and the turkish one is a
translation with validation
of snli and multi-analy into turkish
xnli is a bunch of assessment data sets
that is dev test splits for more than a
dozen languages
drawing on the multi-noise examples
those are human-created translations
that could be used to benchmark
multilingual nli systems
and then there are a few others down
here kind of pointing out trying to get
genre diversity and then nli for
specialized domains uh here's medicine
and science and those could be
interesting for seeing how well a model
can grapple with variation that comes in
very specific and maybe technical
domains
so there's a wide world of tasks you can
explore and i think that makes nli a
really exciting space in which to
develop original systems and projects
and so forth